I don't know right now. Well i think i can consider myself an old timer. You want me to summon it. I'm not nicholson.
And i think i can consider myself an old time and now in this area which is the china newman area.
Although i think you have to be here about sixty years before you consider the true blue all time a but.
Having been here for almost twenty years. I consider myself a veteran of a number of bettles. Have been.
Living on the one property for most of those almost twenty years. Trying to make a go out of living on the land.
Running a nursery. Having some kids. Maintaining a relationship. Which is a full time job in itself.
Fighting for the local forests and staying involved in a lot of other issues and.
Doing university study and a lot of other study as well and trying to maintain my intelligence.
Despite a few problems with. Work overload and so on what i think you have to admit for a start it's the aesthetics.
You can't help being affected by the place. When you walk into it. But it's not just that i think it's the sense of.
The fragility in the face of human onslaughts.
That in itself it's not fret job because it's been around for roughly a hundred million years. So we know.
It's extremely durable. That's withstood a number of. Very dramatic climate changes.
But in the face of what we've had up to it it's become extremely fragile.
And so i think was a combination of these two the beauty and the fragility.
And also the fact that there was so the little if we could see. Quite obviously when we came to the north coast that.
The resident vegetation was on the back foot. And retreating very rapidly it's still used by the way to spot.
Political decisions that make people think it's saved in fact it's still very much in danger.
And so when we came to this area to buy land we particularly wanted to get a bit of ng tech forest.
So we ended up buying a piece of land. Immediately adjacent to a state forest which.
On the surface appeared to looking pretty good shape. But as we became more at it to.
Interpret the signs in the rainforest we can see that there had been some previous damage from logging.
Although if it bit of it was in quite good shape. And so we bonded.
Very quickly to that piece of land not on the land that we fund. But the land adjacent. Because it was very beautiful.
It's at the end of a valley with. Cliffs and tall forest and. Beautiful cloud of things.
So it became very attached this is and. Felt we should. Thought. You know its defense.
When we discovered that it was in fact.
In danger he made it future and that was after a few months after we arrived at the place in seventy four.
We discovered that there were plans to log the forests and loading at that stage meant pretty filling and burning.
And replacing with. Eucalypt forest.
Which twenty years later now it has been discovered to be not a very effective system.
Because the other various timber problems but you can see at the time that it was.
Wasn't a good thing to do to create fill a very complex ecosystem and replace it with a monoculture.
But the prevailing forestry i think at the time was to do this. So i made it reaction was. Terror and.
And need to fought. Actually our initial reaction was to run i have to admit. So land.
But by coincidence a number of people had moved into this area at the same time and.
Just by discussing with other people within days. Card should come back and. We felt yes we would fought this.
And it sprang very quickly the spirit of fighting this issue.
Came to get a very quickly with quite a small bunch of people. That gave me hope the fact that so many people could.
Feel encouraged and feel they might even win.
But i think at the time we had no idea what sort of battle we were talking about what sort of money what sort of toll
in terms of relationships. Money. General lives. It was a really big thing to take on which.
Maybe i wouldn't have done if i'd known how bad it would be yet since i worried about that title for a long time.
The defense of my own backyard is something that i've worried about for some time. Because this is the main accusation.
Thrown at greens. But now i realize that x. Very defensible it's.
It's quite ok to fight for your own backyard infect you everyone should fight for their own backyard
and maybe if we all did that and didn't worry about the global issues. So much.
We could have a consciousness of global issues but if we really concentrated our energies on our local issues.
Something could be done.
And so now i feel much more confident that we can really fought for a very small issue it might even be one tree on the
street. Or it might be in this case. Before thousand activists.
But all of these issues can be fought with enormous vehemence and spirit.
By the people that are most intimately involved. And they're the ones that go on for years.
You get the residents that have lived at a place for fifty years and they're still fighting for the same piece.
I feel the same about this piece of forest that i fought for then. And now that it's on the national park control.
I still worry about it. You know a very intimate relationship.
And i still have arguments with national parks about the way they mesh the place.
Because although we've changed bureaucracies the still the same problem that.
The same concept that the park is there for human use. And we haven't yet switched to this. Major radical.
Mind movement. That these places have got a right to exist. For their own sex the been there a long time without us.
We're very light. Come on. And we don't have to think that we're the most important thing on the planet.
So i still fought for that and yes. It's certainly a deep philosophical.
Association with the idea that these places have a right to exist on their own. And i think.
Along with being embarrassed about fighting for my own backyard i was embarrassed to admit that it might be a
passionate or religious feeling for the land. But now. Again i'm much more confident about that and.
The accusation that. The green movement is somehow religious. Has been thrown about very flippantly.
But i think we can claim that. And not try to throw that away.
Because what else have we got going for us with the demise of so many other religions.
Something has to fill a place because humans do have a need for spirituality.
And what can be more spiritual than the whole planet. So i feel.
We have to grasp it and and fought for something maybe like crusaders which is a bit of a corny image but.
I feel quite strongly that we have to think of ourselves as that. Can use.
On this further on the spiritual side of things. I don't like to a spare.
Obvious dogmas like the hypothesis even though.
I feel that's completely plausible i think it's much more of a personal issue.
But i just happen to have the same personal philosophy along with a lot of other people. And i guess you can call it.
Deep ecology. That there is a name for it now. Well this dark green. Environmentalism a number of names.
A lot of them a derogatory.
But i feel happy to spells those and take them on on them on a very deep level because i feel that.
We're just beginning to learn the dips of spirituality and. Emotional feeling that the aborigines had for the land.
And i knew a bunny lived here twenty years i don't depend on it.
Financially it's not my god it's not my food it's not any of those things but it's still terribly important to me.
So i've got a glimmering of what it meant to those people.
And i feel the more that people can have some sort of feeling for the land.
The more hope we have got of rescuing the planet. Because it's.
This divorce of feeling that has got us into big trouble now. And it's that.
We've now got the land in the relationship that.
The slaves and masters have been in where the master has all the rights and no responsibilities and.
Sex can only really on the slave by destroying it. And that's what we found in australian relationships with land that.
Unless you're doing something to it clearing it or plowing it you don't really own it.
So we have to turn our attitudes to the land on.
On their heads
and include the land in our morality which is very difficult for most australians to feel because they've always had
the frontier attitude that it's a battle. To conquer. Yes. It's very sad that that alienation exists.
Because in the end it will be. Sounds during written doesn't it will be the death of us if we counting start including.
The land. In the way we feel in the way we love. What hope of we've got.
And this increasingly becomes a problem with the dominance of economics as the main mode of thinking that everything
absolutely everything can be translated into.
Dollar terms and so a couple of days ago ross killy talking about that the control of pollution and the.
The reversal of the degradation in rivers has to be tied into economics and i just groaned. Thinking that.
People need to do it for the rivers sake and for the land sec not because it's going to pay them
or not pay them to do the right or wrong thing. That's right.
Yes it's very disturbing especially when you realize that a lot of the activities that are actually degrading.
Contribute to the. G.n.p.
or The economy as a whole needs two things a non-compatible so we maybe have to start thinking about abandoning our
economic system.
Which is very difficult because the belief in perpetual growth is so profound that you virtually can't even bring it up
it's like saying. Mother's milk poisonous or something like that that just doesn't follow.
But we need something as radical as that. And that's what i think the people that. Started working twenty years ago.
Can still contribute a lot because they have that. Basically very radical idea that. The system has to go.
And even though.
I can see are entrenched in the system to some extent we've published books
and we've printed them on paper that came from trees that were filled and we live in a wooden house
and we use the postal system and always other things. I still feel that i can let that go.
If i need to reduce can use it as a vehicle to change minds. But we don't have to be attached to it.
We don't have to be attached to consumerism. As. Not on the a way of life but as an ethic.
And as a duty to keep the economy going. Some of the good product propositions. We have to learn how to let go.
And i think that's what neiman has. With all its problems and all its horrors.
Has really taught a lot of people that you can let go and live a lot more simply.
And another thing i feel very strongly about this. Possibly not. Not a secret from what we've just been talking about.
But i feel strongly that. With all the problems in nimbin in this area.
We didn't have to prove that we could actually solve the whole planet's problems in one go.
It seems unfair to mates is to focus on the. Alcoholics and drug addicts in the streets.
Because look at mainstream society you can't say it's. Squeaky clean it has no problems.
So it's ok to have problems we just have to be proud of the things that that have occurred and a lot of that.
Putting a crack into the main system. The assumption that consumerism is the only way to go.
So i think there's a lot to be proud of. In the last twenty years since been into any creek and all the other issues.
But. Gee there's an awful long way to go as well. And i hear from not in seventy four.
Which is when you and i first discovered that the force was to be logged. There was a campaign.
Until nine hundred seventy nine of. Just the conventional methods of fighting issues.
That was endless letters to ministers endless. Submissions. Appeal for clemency. Invitations to visit the area.
And so on all of which chinked away at the office of forestry expertise but.
We didn't actually get to a point where we could even know that compromise to a certain extent. But we felt in view of.
What was happening to the forests in this area this wasn't really a compromise. So we kept fighting.
And it wasn't until almost the last minute when the blockade started to occur in september
and nine hundred seventy nine that. That the group the main group called to runyon ninety four section group.
Actually contemplated a blockade. We'd always feel.
We must mean before then because the argument seemed to be so apparent.
How could they not listen to what we are saying the naivety staggers me.
We just felt that i would have to exceed to our demands because those so obvious.
And so we didn't actually have a blockade planned at all we joked about it in very light hearted terms
but no one had organized anything. And so when the crunch came and. The bulldozers were definitely coming.
We put out a call at the local market which was a. Called the china market just a local market of crafts.
People put out a call did a couple of minor bits of advertising. And bingo we had. I don't know how many people.
There were at the first day but. About one hundred. Came almost immediately.
Which really floors because we had no idea that be sure taken such a hold on people's imagination.
And fortunately for the people in the to run a united force action group who had been working on the political side
but neglected the social side. The people who came were very good at that stuff. A lot of them came from communities.
And began to work out a social system. Extremely effectively.
And also a physical system for the last aport for cooking washing. Water. Childminding health. Everything else.
Staggered me how quickly they could get that together. And so we all.
Tended to feed off each other we needed to be able to support each other because there were a lot of problems always in
a bunch of people like that there are a lot of personal problems and conflicts and.
Difficulties in solving them especially if you work on the consensus. System and don't have a hierarchy.
So there were problems but.
It was an extremely exciting time when we all felt very strongly that we were doing something very important
and historic. The blockade went on for. I think two or three weeks it's hard to remember not so long ago.
I feel i should have these figures it in my memory but it was about that long.
And not from from the very beginning there were some police involved but these numbers escalated very quickly
when rand attempted to tough it out. And we got up to. Dozens of police at some stage and.
How many twenty twenty petty wagons. We do have some photographs which are quite graphic of the number of.
Blue shirts that they were there.
And as always with all these demonstrations you had some extremely heavy police that were very intimidating.
And on the other scale some who are very supportive. And just said i'm doing my job but. I agree with you.
So there was quite a concerted campaign to tackle the police themselves on a personal level. Not on the gross of level.
And i in particular had an experience when i. For once was up in the forest on my own just getting a bit of.
Because i was so exhausted and came across one of the upper echelon. Cops who was lost.
And i thought oh he's my chance to lose this bastard and make it really embarrassing for and have to do good.
So i in fact chatted with him and talked with him and he was a nice bloke. And laid him out of the forest.
And i think he was grateful because he realised he was very vulnerable. He didn't know the bushies.
Come from somewhere else and he felt the fright of the place or as i felt as if i was in my living room. So.
So at home in pieces or just talking to them treating them like people.
And listening which i've learned subsequently is absolutely vital.
Not to even try and put your ideas across just ask questions and ask how it is for them.
And sometimes you get an enormous. Russia feeling from that person because they may never have been listened to before.
And i particularly noticed this that noddy which was a later. Demonstration for another piece of forest nearby.
When a group of demonstrators
and into the prohibited area of forest where there were some lovers guarding some equipment.
Not that we were threatening it anyway. And some people attacked them verbal a not abusing but.
Yelling arguments at them. And you could see the reaction was a brick wall.
But i perceive that if i just listen to one of the chaps in particular the one with the government on the one who is
really likely to let fly with a fist talking to him he would come down
and it was true it was black magic just listening to his grievances. And finding out what was going on for them was.
Was very important because they have got extremely important grievances that non was listening to.
Still feel strongly that the people at the bottom of the ranks in forestry and in the logging camp.
Other ones that get victimized. All along the line.
They're the ones that get thrown out when you get a mule rationalisations one real taking over another the black.
Dumped it's the bottom blocks that get dumped every time.
When you get a big new machine it's the list skilled ones that get dumped every time.
And now they felt they were being victimised by the greens as well so they were just in an absolutely no win situation.
So i think we few started listening to someone and listen to what they were worried about.
They had plenty to say and we needed to hear that stuff. We couldn't just fourth down ideas on to them.
Because comparatively. The green side. Was more had more internal support.
We had formulated ideas to a certain extent and had a quite a good network of people who knew who felt the same way.
But these logging. Blocks. Felt isolated you could see it.
Very isolated and very threatened and of course your threatened if your livelihood looks like.
Getting shot from under you.
And they're not expecting from us that's written by the mill owner ship as well as we've seen. Subsequently this huge.
Employment losses with these mills are the closing down and taking other mills
or putting in new machines to dusty's book so they were very threatened and.
I think we could have done more in that school. More listening and more actually physically helping these people.
I think the creek in them out knotty issues. Were very formative in bringing.
Many of the greens together and a lot of green thought. But i don't think we can take the credit for.
A lot of the green movement in the area i think that was something that was coming anyway. It was. It was quite clear.
But at the time. The green movement did feel that they support from sydney wasn't forthcoming.
And there's the certainly the urban. Todd. That is that. Certain todd.
Green movement that compared with us was very straight and we certainly looked like the dirty. People in the hills.
Which wasn't true but it. Just the image that. Came across at the time. And so we needed. That the city.
Suited people to to help us help the media realize that in fact. This was a very widespread movement.
Unfortunately when.
Of course the people up here were talking to the media always the cameras go to the most why outlooking crazies.
But the bulk of the movement wasn't base. Wasn't these people it was very straight. Lives more people and.
The people in this area.
In the valleys themselves who might have dressed in suits and ties but had a very well thought up philosophy
and a lot of. A lot of thinking going into the way that they were operating. And also a lot of professional and.
Other expertise. Plenty of people with also advertising in advertising training or. Photographic training or.
Teaching training or. Media training all sorts of different skills that we could apply to the situation.
Yes it's something to be proud of. I think we need. This eerie has had a reputation for breeding. Green extremists.
Which i think is something we can be extremely proud of in fact is not to show that you can buy put out by the local
environments into. Saying green extremists. So that's a good thing but.
I'm a bit worried that the green extremists idea may get hijacked by commercialism and.
Be sold is a nice idea but we really don't have to do anything. Very constructive about this.
And i think that's something that the whole movement in this area has to really worry about that. Our opposition.
The world of economics and.
Commercialism and large bureaucracies that are intent on doing the same as i've always done.
These people have now got the skills to use great ideas. Against us.
And so that the normal person in the street thinks they're doing something useful by using on top.
Paper and feel good about it. But a basically still a major part of the problem.
So i think that's the next challenge for us.
We appear to have had a major green that looks like people really care about this. These issues.
But underneath it all has been a very minor change and. That's what we have to work on the story.
There's certainly been a very strong and green movement. Coming to being since the.
Especially that to any great battle. Where for a start.
We were hidden because we had all the innovative ideas such as using advertising which hadn't been thought of for a
green issue before. So we were hit on that score but now. There's a problem with the backlash. To that and.
An increasing sophistication of. Technics from large bureaucracy such as advertising and.
Getting across what i consider to be false information.
But i'm not too concerned about the backlash against green movement scene the general population i think that is
actually diminishing and. Green ideas are increasing because the evidence is so apparent.
We don't have to pretend that it's not happening. So i think the violent. And he green movements. Will go in time.
But we have to deal with to mediate future is the apathy and the belief that it's all ok.
So i think you get people like the more extreme members of the force your protection. Society. Association.
Should know these terms such as rage. What's that rational. Action against green. Extremists.
Rational action i think against green extremists.
I can see where these people come from that come from a position of fear and. Powerlessness and.
It's easy to attribute causes and the green one green. The greens are the most obvious cause.
So they will continue to be a problem but. That will diminish. What we have to guard against increasing apathy.
Such as it's quite obvious that the greenhouse effect having a big impact on public consciousness for the first year
or two that was talked about and it's not discussed too openly. Oh. So you know.
Yes the green movement certainly has to start offering some positive alternatives. We have been saying.
No for a very long time and. Unfortunately. Getting the image of course there were very negative and.
Against everything. But i think that's reasonable.
Not to have the solutions when you're pointing to a problem it's like a doctor saying you've got cancer and.
They mightn't have the answers but they still have to point out that you've got a problem.
So i think it's reasonable for us to do that. But of course. To increase public.
Credibility we do have to provide more in the way of positive answers.
Not that we haven't been doing this for some time talking about reforestation being. Number one priority.
You know as area with. Huge percentage of degraded land that we have.
This is obviously a big question which could solve a lot of employment problem solving their relation problem.
Solve a lot of planetary problems. So we haven't been neglecting this issue but we have to do it more effectively.
And i think. As far as i'm concerned the economics is a major problem. And so the green people have.
Showed more explicitly how to leave. Very softly on the earth. And this means. Scaling down.
Economic involvement out of a desire to have things.
And becoming really socially mobile as some of the people on bodie have suggested it's a very good idea that we have to
stop aspiring to earn more things which obviously have a terminal impact on the planet.
So we have to sever ties the economic system. From within.
And this will have enormous ramifications for the forestry industry apart from anything else.
We're not saying don't use trees we're saying. Use an awful lot less.
The me at the moment that goes for everything else as well.
So i think of greens can show themselves to be capable of living lot the on the planet. And.
Coming up with some alternative suggestions. They're going to look a lot more.
Be looked on a lot more favorably by the general populace. At the moment we have a few people that consider that.
Having a rosewood table is ok if you had a rosewood. But as far as i'm concerned.
One seedling doesn't make will one thousand year old tree.
We have to do a lot more than that we have to start using pine. For instance which you and i've done in this house.
Because those ponds are in the ground now we should use them and not keep using the old force that.
No matter how great it sowed to plant a tree is just really not going to work. We have to back off for some period now.
That these forests and.
Indeed the whole country recover from the difficult one because you can see the economic impact will be enormous.
That's why we have to escape from this straight jacket. Of economic consciousness that we have at the moment.
That that money is what will count.
Money will get us out of our problems increased growth increased use of resources will get us out of these problems
and. A child can say that. This is a nonsense. Working out how to stay green and be completely not here.
Critical and completely pure. Is extremely difficult and decide it is completely impossible.
And for a long time of being vulnerable to the accusation of. Well you drive a car.
You wear shoes you walk on wooden floors.
And i still worry about that one not still want to be as pure as possible while realizing that if i was obsessed with.
Consuming things i'd been out on the. Contributing to the g.n.p.
but I'd be untroubled by feelings if you talk to see i would not since. Be a good person.
Whereas now i feel that if i cut a tree down on my property to make a fence post.
I'm somehow involved in a you know hypocrisy. But i'm coming to terms with that. And i think.
All i can do is use my base and. Most people in fact do that all the time.
But we greens have to be even more aware of that and not let ourselves slip into into bad ways. But i'm aware that.
You know no history for instance we produce. Hundreds of thousands of trees every year. Sounds like a great idea.
But we use plastic pots.
We use recycled ones where we can but we still use some new ones so we're very open to accusations of. Bad practices.
Because i haven't personally investigated the factory that makes these plastic pots
and no doubt it's dumping it's learned into the local creek who know us.
And where you send that strange from the river. And no doubt the sands there because the slopes have been cleared.
And so. I'm still responsible for everything that goes on.
I'm really aware that i personally have got a stake in the whole degradation of the planet.
So although this can give you an enormous load of guilt. You have to somehow. Put that on the one shoulder.
Not have it on bus shoulders. So use your guilt as a motivator.
Motivating force to keep you as clean as you possibly can but don't be overwhelmed by it
and that is the trick for almost all the greens i now know operating the veterans of these old campaigns.
Of how to manage the guilt button. And the. Hypocrisy burden. And still be effective. Positive. Happy.
People who know they've got an issue to work on. And don't want to be crippled by. The feelings that.
The maybe something wrong with what they're doing. For instance i use a car.
And i'm very aware of that that i would step a lot more likely on the planet if i walked instead of driving.
But the problems of the moment are so crucial that you have to shortcut
and second use the paraphernalia of the opposition. To thought it. So that's why i use a computer which no doubt.
Had see if c's involved in its manufacture. The list of people proceeds is endless.
I just try to get them under control. Thank you. It's a very sore. Looking back now after twenty years.
From an experiment. On.
I've come to the conclusion that the ethics and ideas of the original newton people were and are still correct.
But often they are. Thwarted by just the prevailing lack of energy and hopelessness even of a lot of people.
Now unfortunately the people who are doing all the destroying of the planet.
The ones that got all the energy
and initiative other ones have got precisely the wrong ideas about stimulating the economy and consuming more and.